the great thing about films like this is
that they take us places that you know
you can't get in your car and drive to
the Arctic this is such an intimate look
at a vast place and the changes that are
being made there have such implications
for all of us down in the temperate
world in winter 30 below is the norm
it's lovely weather for polar bear
families Greg MacGillivray and I've
worked together before I have so much
admiration for him and his team and how
they have captured sort of impossible
subjects and made them available to us
in the most vivid ways it's unimaginable
that they could capture this stuff I'm
so glad to be part of it
you know now as we get these formats
that are smaller and smaller and smaller
there is some great impact in seeing
something huge especially on a subject
matter that is so monumental in scale as
the Arctic is and I think it's a more
sort of total experience to be in the
IMAX format you are surrounded by the
visuals it's an amazing thing and I'm
very excited for audiences to see it
from Warner Brothers pictures and IMAX
present a spectacular adventure to the
Arctic